well I'm joined Now by former senior
military intelligence and security
officer Philip Ingram Phillip hello to
you again let's let's start with the
missile strikes that Alex was talking
about across Ukraine last night
how widespread were they very widespread
both in geographic terms and in the
types of missiles that we used but they
hit the cities of key of kharkiv Odessa
crevieria de nipro where we saw that
apartment block the appalling attack in
the apartment block and Venezia um in
the in the East interestingly um the
suggestions that the missiles that
attack Kiev were fired from inside
Belarus no the Russians have overflown
missiles from Belarus beforehand and
they've got troops in Belarus but um
they're trying to Big up more activity
from there okay
let's talk about the type of missiles
because it's been reported that there
was a variety of missiles that what's
the significance of that huge variety of
missiles you know ranging from the S 300
S 400 air defense missiles um and these
are the s-300s that were seen on the the
um practice of the victory period in
Moscow with the coloring on the side
that's used in Ukraine
um modified to for a ground attack rule
they're ballistic missiles so they go up
very high and then come down
ballistically on onto a Target the other
possibility
was the Alexander M which is a
land-based missile launched from the
back of a a truck that we can we can see
here now for those that are
knowledgeable out there that's Alexander
K it's a cruise missile the the m is a
ballistic missile with a a range of
thousands of kilometers and a warhead up
to 700 kilograms and then we've seen
lots of cruise missiles there's lots of
different variants of those that are air
launched or sea launched
um and some anti-ship missiles the
variety that we're seeing that have been
used
um across the board suggests that the
Russians don't have any one particular
missile that's doing what they need
they're trying to penetrate the
Ukrainian defenses but they also are
running out of missiles and some of
these missiles have of
um Warheads up to a thousand kilograms a
ton of high explosives okay let's let's
talk about equipment because we have
we've had Russian accent but sending
Challenger two tanks over and we've had
a bit more information about what else
they're going to be giving to the
ukrainians just fill us in on that we we
have and we've heard that they're going
to send 14 Challenger two tanks now that
is the equivalent of a British Army
Challenger 2 Squadron of Tanks
um three troops um of four and then two
in the red to Middle headquarters for
the commanding officer and his team to
be able to go forward there's probably
another couple of um Challenger armored
repair and Recovery vehicles that need
to go and accompany them but that's the
smallest fighting unit that could get
out there and have an effect on the
ground and then of course some more as90
155 millimeter self-propelled guns that
have got a range of up to 25 kilometers
and that's significant there's they're
sending 30 of those that's more than a
regiment's worth in Predator army terms
okay Philip fascinating as always thank
you very much